let's take the biggest surprise we've
had today the departure of Michael Gove
from education to become chief whip and
James is this anything other than a
demotion number 10 ours are stressing
that it's not but I saying he's going to
be attending the 830 and the four
o'clock and downing street it's going to
be on every cabinet sub-committee they
aren't saying that with the general
metroing 10 mops away they won't go in
number 10 all the time they want this
big political brain at the center but
also trying to say there's no slowing
down on the education reform agenda I
personally with one that a lot more
credible it goes junior minister list
Ross had simply moved up become
education secretary because they're
pretty much alike yeah they are
basically exact on exactly the same page
on rigor on the importance of maps and
all these things instead we've got Nicky
Morgan coming in from the Treasury with
no previous demonstrated in interest in
education policy to become education
secretary and Liz truss going off to do
the environment briefing cabinet now I
think this adds of a suspicion that they
decided but the reform agenda the
ideological elements of it that do upset
some teachers undoubtedly um but they've
just become too difficult so we decided
to park that between between now and the
election in 10 months x one of the
ironies is one of the things that is
cited a things that michael gove as set
as education sexually that of upset
David Cameron is when he said that um it
was preposterous how many old Etonians
they were in government sadly feel that
by moving his education sector they've
made it much more likely than in 30
years time the Tory party was still and
all political parties we're still be
arguing about how many private educated
people are are in the government because
this was the man who is doing more for
state education more to drive up
standards a man who was prepared to
sacrifice his own political career for
that and he's now gone from the
department education I mean that's very
sad day so see you think then this
actually will make immeasurable in fact
what you're saying quite profound
difference to the education reform
Alban is going to go in there and dilute
it but what I think you're going to see
is that Michael Gove was constantly had
it you know the pedal to the metal you
know the department were basically agin
him as well where exactly he drove on I
was prepared to go to debating just push
on pause the reform I I think Nikki
woman is just not going to do that um
now I think that lots of people are
saying that she is the kind of Jeremy
Hunt of in the same way that Jeremy Hunt
took over the Health Department
obviously untrue Nancy reforms and kind
of tried to get a modifier everyone and
that she lacked the kind of parents
champion in the way that hunt is actor
the patient's champion I do think it
would be a much more reassuring if gonna
blizz trust was there it's going to keep
the go Vijender going it's bill does it
seem as if the government then is almost
giving up on its own reform agenda and
as decided that year five is going to be
about presentation rather than action I
think that's definitely the case not
just with gave leaving education but
also if you look at Nick Boles who was
installed as planning minister was
making burgers wasn't he well he was
making progress in the debate and he was
very good at articulating why the
Conservatives ship again become the
party of house building but he was
associated with some of the more toxic
and flawed planning reforms and it's
just basically being ditched so I don't
know he has gone on to a bigger job at
education under the good i think it's
still a sign that actually that they
don't think that keeping him in planning
even though he does have expertise from
Policy Exchange in education keeping him
at planning they don't think was a safe
thing to do and I think that's one of
the things that's happened at this
reshop is they're trying to neutralize
things that I have a little bit more
sympathy with the Nicky Morgan argument
in that she is a completely fresh face
you can present the education reforms in
what number ten clearly perceives as a
non-toxic way do you think number ten is
beginning to feel that the teachers
unions have got a point and that go fit
maybe they might argue that sure you
need to confront to get things done but
right now when you're a lightning rod
for teacher to defection and the opinion
polls show even the average parent it
thinks there's something confrontational
going on here the go was a bit too
that you risk ah I suspect that might
have been the case because I think labor
was starting to feel that they had a bit
of currency in arguing that the
education big tent was somehow falling
apart that that they could set up their
own separate temp because Gove was so
aggressive if you look at figures like
Lord of doughnuts who used to obviously
be very keen to praise Michael Gove but
who are less so nowadays that there's a
sense actually that perhaps Michael go
for all his amazing ideological drive
and desire to improve education so that
people who can't afford to send their
kids to private school still get the
choice that private school parents do
actually maybe it's good to have
somebody else selling those achievements
in the run-up to the general election I
don't know it depends whether you think
that spin or substance more important in
the next few months and she was about
the swaging the lib dems I mean do you
think I imagined em Nick Clegg will go
to bed tonight a happier man knowing the
Michael Gove is not an education anymore
but only Nick label go spread that much
happier man because he doesn't like for
the payment at all for the payment is
now foreign secretary with his very
Euroskeptic leanings which is going to
concern Nick Clegg the defense of the
government from from from those who are
very close to him is this is frankly
nothing else matters for the next ten
months apart from winning the general
action the best way to entrench the
education reforms is the Tories to win
in 2015 they argue having Michael at the
center I'm doing it doing a bit of
mollifying of teachers if that makes it
more likely that so that's a price well
worth paying I'm only pointing away
those that the camera is taking a gamble
here because he's basically saying right
I'm going to risk what I've done what
I've achieved so far on trying to win
the next election and if I do then we
can do more but if I lose I already
would have become begun the retreat that
will make it that much easier for labor
to dismantle my reform